so it's day 3 of the Democrats opening
arguments in president Trump's
impeachment trial and it's just about to
begin now as I say this is their final
day this is when the Republicans and
their lawyers will have the same amount
of time three days we think in order to
rebut the accusations that have been
made by the Democrats including
withholding military aid to force
Ukraine to dig up dirt on his rival the
former Vice President Joe Biden
president Trump denies any wrongdoing
without more ado let's go live to our
White House correspondent Kimberly
halket who is there at the White House
so day three then of the Democrats and
the prosecution if you like do we have
any idea as to what the strategy might
be will they just continue with what
many people have said has been a fairly
sort of repetitive and monotonous
diatribe that has sent many of the
Senators to sleep well they will because
that's what they're mandated to do in
the final day of arguments the house
managers meticulously making their case
which at times has been very scathing
and damning for the president the
problem is often when you're building a
legal case it's not particularly
riveting television and that has been a
challenge not just to keep the attention
of the senators who act as the jurors in
this trial but also the American public
as you know many and there in the
chamber are hoping to influence the
outcome of the 20s or rather 2020 u.s.
election you have to remember that some
of those senators sitting in that
chamber are also running for president
to replace Donald Trump so that has even
opened them up to some sort of criticism
about just how objective they can really
be I think it's safe to assume this has
been a partisan exercise from the
beginning in many respects and the
president continuing to try and weigh in
where he can as well in the last hour
he's been tweeting the do-nothing
Democrats just keep repeating and
repeating over and over the same old
stuff on the impeachment hoax the
president continues to try to discredit
these proceedings and continues to
maintain that he
admitted no wrongdoing and says that he
has not in any way as the Democrats
accused leveraged his political and
presidential powers in order to try to
win re-election and what about the earth
that every senator took of the start of
this this process and that it was to be
an impartial juror and yet it seems very
much as though many of the Republicans
and in fact the Democrats have already
made up their minds as to which way they
would vote altom Utley you're absolutely
right it doesn't seem I think that that
dynamic could change if in fact and this
is something that could happen next week
with the not only the arguments in terms
of the defense aspect of it those
lawyers who will be arguing the case on
the part of President trumpet also if we
do have a bit of drama in terms of
witnesses that is still yet to be
decided but if for example someone like
the former national security adviser
John Bolton were to testify something
that this US president has certainly
pushed back on citing executive
privilege that could certainly change
the dynamic that could not only make
them more engaged but you could see
potentially some Republicans and
moderate Republicans who control that
chamber crossing over with Democrats but
right now none of that has happened so
you're absolutely true in stating that
most of them went in with their minds
made up and they haven't changed in any
way they have not been swayed that has
been the challenge for Jeff Democrats
trying to make that case but as we've
heard from our own reporters who have
been inside the chamber observing as the
producers as well they you know there
have been some that have fallen asleep
others have been playing with little
fidget spinners so far this has not been
particularly engaging and that is the
problem for Democrats who are ultimately
seeking to remove president Trump from
office after being impeached in the
House of Representatives late last year
right and so today as we've said
Kimberly's day three of the allotted
time for the house managers to
mount their case and and then that will
be followed by the Republicans now you
were telling me earlier Kimberly that
you thought the Republicans might not
even take up the full three days that
they are entitled to absolutely right
and a couple of clues as to why we're
thinking that number one I went into the
White House yesterday and said are you
guys going to use your full three days
they have 24 hours stretched over three
days to make their case and well they
wouldn't fully answer the question the
the source I was talking to said you
know maybe not we further heard from the
president's own attorney longtime
personal attorney Jay Sekulow who spoke
very publicly saying that we will use as
much time as is needed
that's another signal in Washington
speak that they're not going to use the
full amount of time
having said that Martine the source I
spoke to inside the White House also
told me I that they can make a plan and
this has been the case from day one in
Donald Trump's presidency and then that
plan is literally just thrown into the
garbage the second Donald Trump changes
his mind so if he doesn't see this going
the way he would like and he certainly
wants his opportunity to defend himself
they have said repeatedly from the White
House side that they don't believe the
President had due process or the
opportunity to cross-examine or make the
president's case he's very much a thin
skinned president he doesn't like this
stain that's on him the tarnish of
impeachment that goes into the history
books
so he's looking to clear his name and
he's a master at manipulating the media
in terms of getting across his message
so expected from the White House he will
be producing this very much in order to
try and make his case to the American
people if he needs more time there's
that possibility that he could in fact
take it
all right Kimberly thanks for that I
think it's probably time now that we can
go over to the chamber and listen
hearing no objection so ordered
the sergeant in arms will make the
proclamation
here you here you here you all persons
are commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment while the Senate of the
United States is sitting in a trial of
the articles of impeachment exhibited by
the House of Representatives against
Donald John Trump President of the
United States Justice the majority
leader is recognized or all of our
colleagues some information about
scheduling today we'll plan to take
short breaks every two to three hours
and will accommodate a 30-minute recess
for dinner assuming it is needed until
the house managers have finished their
opening presentation with scheduling
purposes we've organized tomorrow's
session to convene in 10 a.m. and run
for several hours as the president's
counsel begins their presentation
pursuant to the provisions of Senate
resolution 483 the managers for the
House of Representatives have 7 hours
and 53 minutes remaining to make the
presentation of their case the Senate
will now hear you mr. Chief Justice
senators distinguished Council of the
President I keep wanting to say good
morning but good afternoon I just wanted
to give a very brief orientation to the
argument you'll hear today we will begin
with Jason crow who was talking about
the conditionality of the military
assistance this is the latter part
although not the end of the
argumentation on the application of the
Constitution and law as it respects
article 1 the abuse of power I'll have a
presentation after mr. crow and soon
thereafter we will conclude the
presentation on article 1 will then
begin the presentation on article 2 once
again
applying the Constitution and law to the
facts on the presidents of Stark
of Congress we will then have some
concluding thoughts and then turn it
over to the President's Council and that
is what you should expect for the day
and with that I will now yield to mr.
krill of Colorado good afternoon I woke
up this morning and walked to my local
coffee shop where unlike my esteemed
colleague mr. Jeffries from New York
nobody complained to me about Colorado
baseball so I could only conclude that
this is only a New York Yankees problem
as mr. Schiff mentioned we talked last
night about the July 25th call and the
multiple officials who confirmed the
intent of the president in withholding
the aid so now I'd like to turn to what
happened around the time that the aid
was lifted and we know that the aid was
lifted ultimately on September 11th but
it wasn't lifted for any legitimate
reason it was only lifted because
President Trump had gotten caught now
let's go through how we know that on
August 26 the whistleblower complaint
had been sent to the Director of
National Intelligence and public reports
indicate that President Trump was told
about the complaint by White House
Counsel Pat's abalone on some tipper
fifth though the scheme became public an
editorial in the Washington Post on that
day for the first time publicly
explicitly linked the military aid hold
and the investigations that President
Trump wanted now keep in mind that
public scrutiny of the president's hold
increased exponentially after this
became public and this is where things
start moving really fast a few days
later on September 9th the House
investigative committees publicly
announced their investigation of
president's conduct in Ukraine
Lieutenant Colonel vid Minh testified
that the nationalistic
security council and others at the White
House learned about the investigation
when it was announced and a colleague of
his said that it might have the effect
of releasing the aide and on that same
day the House Intelligence Committee
learns that the administration had
withheld the whistleblower complaint
from Congress the scheme was unraveling
and what happens two days later
President Trump released the military
aid he only released it after he got
caught but there's another reason we
know the president lifted the aide only
because he got caught because there's no
other explanation the testimony of all
of the witnesses confirms it both
lieutenant-colonel vid Minh and Miss
Williams testified that they were not
provided any reason for lifting the hold
then men testified that nothing on the
ground had changed in the two months of
the hold and mark sandy of the OMB could
also confirm that an ambassador Taylor
too testified that quote I was not told
the reason why the hold had been lifted
now let me take a moment to address
another defense I expect you will hear
that the aide was released and the
investigations were never announced so
therefore no harm no foul right well
this defense would be laughable if this
issue wasn't so serious
first I've spoken over the past three
days about the real consequences of
inserting politics into matters of war
real people real lives are at stake
every day every hour matters so know the
delay wasn't meaningless just ask the
Ukrainians sitting in trenches right now
and to this day they are still waiting
on 18 million dollars of the aid that
hasn't reached them Jennifer Williams
who attended the Warsaw meeting with
Vice President Prince described
President zelinsky's focus during this
time and you testified in your
deposition that in that conversation
President Solinsky emphasized that the
military system
the security assistance was not just
important to assist Ukraine in fighting
a war against Russia but that it was
also symbolic in nature and what did you
what did you understand him to mean by
that president Solinsky explained that
more than or just equally with the
financial and physical value of the
assistance that it was the symbolic
nature of that assistance that really
was the show of u.s. support for Ukraine
and for Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and I think he was
he was stressing that to the
vice-president to really underscore the
need for the Security Assistance to be
released and that if the United States
was holding the Security Assistance is
it also true then that Russia could see
that as a sign of weakening u.s. support
for Ukraine and take advantage of that I
believe that's what the president
president zelanski was was indicating
that any signal or sign that US support
was wavering would be construed by
Russia as potentially an opportunity for
them to strengthen their own hand in
Ukraine this is an important point
particularly when the president and his
attorneys try to argue no harm no foul
the financial assistance itself was
really important to Ukraine no question
about it but the aid was equally
important as a signal to Russia of our
support for Ukraine and regardless of
whether the aid was ultimately released
the fact that the hold became public
sent a very clear signal to Russia that
our support for Ukraine was wavering in
Russia was watching very closely for any
sign of weakness the damage was done now
any possible doubt about whether the aid
was linked to the investigations has
been erased by the president's own chief
of staff and we've seen this video
before during the trial but there's a
really good reason for this it's a
complete admission on national TV that
the military aid was conditioned on
Ukraine helping the president's
political campaign here once again is
what Mulvaney said that he also
mentioned to me and past the the the the
the corruption
related to the DNC server absolutely no
question about that but that's it that's
why we held up the money and when
pressed that he had just confessed to
the very quid pro quo that President
Trump had been denying Mulvaney doubled
down let's be clear you just described
is a quid pro quo it is funding will not
flow unless the investigation into the
into the democratic server happened as
well we do we do that all the time with
foreign policy if you read the news
reports and you believe them what a
McKinney's say yesterday
well McKinney said yesterday that he was
really upset with the political
influence in foreign policy that was one
of the reasons he was so upset about
this and I have news for everybody get
over it there's going to be political
influence and foreign policy I'm talking
now remember at the time he made these
statements bovania was both the head of
OMB and the acting chief of staff at the
White House he knew about all of the
legal concerns he also knew about the
president's so-called drug deal as
ambassador Bolton called it he knew
exactly what was going on in the Oval
Office and how OMB implemented the
president's illegal order to hold the
eight Mulvaney confirmed why the
president ordered the hold it was not to
develop further policy to counter
Russian aggression it was not to
convince the Ukrainians to implement
additional anti-corruption reforms and
it was not to pressure our allies to
give more to Ukraine now since we won't
have an opportunity to respond to the
president's presentation I'm going to
take a minute to respond to some of the
arguments that I expect them to make you
will notice I'm sure that they will
ignore significant portions of the
evidence while trying the cherry-pick
individual statements here and there to
manufacture defenses but don't be fooled
one defense you may hear is that the aid
was held up to allow for a policy review
this is what the administration told the
GAO at one point but the two evidence
shows the opposite the evidence shows
that the administration didn't conduct a
review at any time after the president
ordered the whole Laura Cooper
was not aware of any review of the
funding conducted by DoD in July August
or September and similarily George Kent
testified that the State Department did
not conduct and was never asked to
conduct a review of funding
administrator by the State Department in
fact on May 23rd the anti-corruption
review was complete and DOD certified to
Congress that Ukraine had complied with
all of the conditions and that the
remaining half of the aid should be
released this was confirmed by the June
18th press release announcing the
release or announcing the the funding
and do you remember the fictitious the
fictitious quote/unquote interagency
review process
well that was made up - so no review was
necessary because it had already been
done next the President's Council keeps
saying this was about corruption in
Ukraine President Trump was not
concerned with fighting corruption it's
difficult to even say that with a
straight face the president never
mentioned corruption on either a call
with President szalinski but let's go
through the evidence as we just
discussed DoD had already completed a
review and concluded that Ukraine had
quote made sufficient progress in
meeting defense reform and
anti-corruption goals consistent with
the National Defense Authorization Act
in order to receive the funds and in
fact mark sandy who was not at that
meeting but who was initially
responsible for approving the hold said
he had never heard corruption as a
reason for the hold in all of the
discussions he had about it similar to
the anti-corruption argument there is
simply no evidence to support the
president's after-the-fact
argument that he was concerned about
burden sharing now that's other
countries also contributing to Ukraine I
imagine the president may cite the
emails in June about what other
countries provided to Ukraine the
reference to other countries
contributions in the July 25th call and
testimony from Sandy about a request for
information about what other European
countries give to Ukraine but there are
simply no evidence that
heis the concern to his decision to hold
the funding first let's actually look at
the contributions of European countries
to Ukraine all right we're going to
leave the Republican senator Jason crow
of Colorado as he meticulously outlines
his case giving a contextual account of
the geopolitics and of the the
consequences if you like of the of the
withholding of the aid this is just
maybe the first 15 minutes or so of the
7 hours and 53 minutes that remain for
the Democrats to make their case there a
Michals to persuade some of those
Republicans enough of those Republicans
to reconsider their support for
president Trump so we'll leave that and
move on to some other news